this is an ideology that has spread
there was a tick tock video that just
went viral
of some kooky liberal woman
holding a little baby she's a white
woman all her kids are white
she's holding a little white baby and
she's got two other little white kids
and she instructs her children to kneel
down and worship
black women black women
are the reason that donald trump is no
longer going to be our president
all hail black women
all hail black women you know on
sundays i go to the traditional latin
mass
usually sometimes i have to go to not
latin mass usually it's the traditional
latin mass the smells and the bells the
gregorian chant
and some people say michael that's a
little weird oh man that's that liturgy
is pretty weird
i don't think it's even one one
zillionth
as strange even to out outsiders as this
liturgy of liberalism whereby little
children are made
to kneel and worship black women there
are these votive candles these sort of
like you know very religious
iconography all over the candles of
stacy abrams
i seriously it's like peak liberal white
woman is
that sort of a candle but this
is we can laugh about it this is a
dangerous ideology
if you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the subscribe button so everyone waiting
through the wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there